my baby sister died that hit me how old
was she she was 40
that really hit me because she had
she had cancer a couple times and we
beat it so when they told me she had
cancer again i figured we're gonna beat
it
but then it was just too late and then
one day i'm downstairs working out with
my youngest son shakir one of my other
son comes in in the gym and he's crying
and then i see the the kobe thing
so now i'm like i got to be a hoax
because i was watching the game when
brian passed them up
probably just somebody messing around on
the on the internet
and then the cars just kept coming in
and then you go watch tv
and it just
just hit
it put me in a i shoulda mowed i should
have spent more time with my sister
i should have reached out the young
fella
i should have just called to just check
on i shoulda
and you know things like that you can
never get back